Do you like scary movies?
If you’re a fan of horror, there have probably
been quite a few times where you’ve found
yourself yelling at the movie screen: “Don’t
go up to the attic!”
“Don’t split up!”
“Don’t check out the noise in the basement,
run out the front door!”
You know the characters can’t hear you,
but when the story is engaging enough to make
you care about their well-being, you can’t
help but try and give them a hand.
After all, you’d want someone to save you
from a machete-wielding maniac stalking through
the summer camp you took up your new counselor
job at.
If someone was watching you hide in the closet,
listening for a masked killer’s footsteps
with a kitchen knife in your hand, you’d
want them to give you a heads up when the
killer was getting ready to chop through the
door with an axe!
Of course, the characters in your favorite
movies never listen.
Because, you know, that’s how movies work.
But in 1985, a young man returned a VHS tape
entitled “Return of the Suburb Slasher”
to his local video store with a peculiar complaint:
the main character of the movie stopped mid-action
to look at the camera, and beg for his help.
The video store clerk laughed him off, and
refused to give him a refund - though he did
eventually give in and offer store credit
after the man began to cry.
He decided to take the tape home and watch
it, just to see what all the fuss was about.
After all, he’d never seen someone cry at
a horror movie like that.
So he sat down on his favorite beanbag chair,
pushed the tape into the VCR, and pressed
play.
Apparently his shell-shocked customer had
at least remembered to be kind and rewind.
The movie told the story of Heather Campbell,
a young woman planning to host a party at
her family’s home in a classic suburban
cul-de-sac while her parents are out of town.
In equally classic slasher fashion, this party
would take place on the 10th anniversary of
a series of grisly murders in the same neighborhood,
committed by the mysterious Suburb Slasher.
As the party kicks off with loud music, teenage
debauchery, and lots of drinking out of red
plastic cups, the killer appears to pick off
the group of friends one by one.
Like other classic slasher villains, your
Michael’s and your Jason’s, the Suburb
Slasher also covers their face, wearing a
black burlap sack over their head that masks
all identifiable features.
The first 90 minutes of the movie were fun,
but basic.
A canoodling couple gets decapitated here,
an unnecessary shower scene is cut short by
a stabbing there, the sort of thing you’d
expect.
But at about 97 minutes in, something impossible
happened.
Heather walked into the living room, finding
her friends’ dead bodies strewn across it,
and let out a scream that measured up to the
bests in the genre.
The teen scream queen then began to run, as
the killer appeared to chase her.
She made her way into the basement of the
house, locking the door behind her.
Then, she turned to the camera, tears in her
eyes, shirt spattered with blood, and said:
“Hey Mister, I don’t know you, and I don’t
know why you’ve just sat there watching
this without doing nothing, but please.
I’m begging you, help me out here.
What can I do to survive this?”
At first, the clerk thought he was under the
influence of some mind-altering substance,
but the only things in his system were popcorn
and store-brand soda.
No, this was really happening.
He stared, open-mouthed, at the screen, where
Heather watched him expectantly.
He was too stunned to speak.
After a moment of silence, Heather sighed
dejectedly, shaking her head, and turned back
toward the stairs.
She slowly walked back to the basement door,
unlocked it, and pulled it open.
There, the killer was waiting with his expressionless
burlap mask.
The clerk’s eyes widened, and he cried out
“No!”
but it was too late.
The film suddenly cut to black, and with a
whirring sound, the VCR spat the tape back
out.
The clerk sat there, staring at the tape.
What could he do with it?
Should he make a copy, send it to someone
else and pass the curse along?
Should he try to watch it again?
He wasn’t sure he could bear to see Heather
looking at him with those same pleading eyes.
Then, he remembered an ad he had seen in the
back of his favorite comic book: “Seen something
you can’t explain?
A brush with the unknown keeping you up at
night?
We’re looking for stories of the strange
and unusual!
Write to us now!”
Maybe they could do something that he couldn’t.
He put the tape back into its cover, placed
it in an envelope, and mailed it off the next
day.
A few days later, the package reached its
intended recipient: an undercover branch of
the SCP Foundation tracking anomalous activity
via a series of ads in comic books and video
stores to tap into one of the most underutilized
resources in the world: nerds.
The tape was designated SCP-5733, and Heather
and the masked killer were designated SCP-5733-2
and SCP-5733-1, respectively.
After an initial viewing confirmed its anomalous
properties, a research team headed by Dr.
Carpenter began to perform a series of tests.
Testing was open to all Foundation employees,
subject to approval by Dr. Carpenter.
Approved personnel would be placed in a Site
73 multipurpose room with a VHS player and
a television.
The staff member would then watch the movie,
and attempt to engage with Heather and help
her escape.
For the first test, D-Class 1973 was selected.
When Heather turned to the camera and asked
for help, he asked if she had a car.
When she confirmed that yes, she did, he instructed
her to sneak back upstairs, find her car keys,
leave through the back door, and drive as
fast and as far away as possible.
She successfully retrieved the car keys, but,
when she reached the car, she saw that the
tires had been slashed.
Heather began to panic, but 1973 talked her
through it, telling her to smash the window
of a neighbor’s car and unlock the door.
She complied, and 1973 instructed her on how
to hot-wire the vehicle.
The car started, and with a triumphant laugh
she sped out of the cul-de-sac.
Just as her car began to pull away, the killer
emerged from the backseat, wielding a kitchen
knife.
Heather screamed, and the tape cut to black.
For the next test, D-Class 1944 was selected.
He began by telling Heather to find her father’s
shotgun, seen earlier in the film, and use
it to take out the killer before they could
get to her.
She snuck up to her parents’ room and found
the gun, only for the killer to appear in
the doorway behind her.
She aimed the gun and fired…but nothing
happened.
The killer opened their hand, dropping the
shotgun’s shells on the floor.
She was close, but the killer was one step
ahead.
She screamed as they approached with the knife,
and again, the tape cut to black.
After several tests were conducted with D-class
subjects, and no adverse effects were reported
- aside from the obvious trauma of failing
to save Heather’s life - testing was opened
up to all Foundation staff.
Assistant Researcher Felissa Baker volunteered.
She believed her extensive knowledge of the
slasher genre would give her the tools to
help Heather strategize.
After speaking with Heather about her skills,
which mainly included party planning and babysitting,
Felissa determined that Heather should seek
outside help.
With Felissa’s help, Heather made her way
out of the house and over to the home of her
next door neighbor, Mr. Loomis.
When she got there, the door was open, and
the lights were off.
It didn’t look great, but she didn’t really
have much of a choice but to go inside.
She made her way to the bedroom, where Mr.
Loomis and his wife were lying in bed.
She tried to wake him, but the camera zoomed
in to reveal his throat had been slashed.
The shape in bed next to him sat up, and was
not in fact his wife, but the Suburb Slasher
instead.
As the figure raised their signature kitchen
knife, the screen went black.
SCP-5733 became a competition of sorts among
Foundation staff, each volunteer proposing
their knowledge would help them get Heather
to safety.
Assistant Researcher Nick Englund-Daskewisz
proposed telling Heather to call for help,
giving her a secret phone number for the SCP
Foundation circa 1983, the time in which the
movie was set.
However, when Heather reached the phone, it
had been destroyed, smashed into pieces.
Next to it was a note, written in blood, that
said: “The only Foundation here is FEAR.”
Then, the killer appeared behind Heather,
and the tape went black.
Somehow, the killer knew about the SCP Foundation.
Perhaps, in a manner of speaking, the call
was coming from inside the house.
Next, Field Agents Malcolm Pleasance and Donald
McDowell were selected due to their extensive
knowledge of hand-to-hand combat.
They attempted to teach Heather various fighting
and self-defense techniques, while she survived
on the limited supplies available in the basement.
She eventually left the basement, and, when
the killer appeared, began to fight them.
After twenty three minutes of combat, she
knocked the Slasher to the floor, and grabbed
a candlestick to finish them off.
As the agents watching began to celebrate,
a second version of the Suburban Slasher appeared
behind her, lunging forward.
Just before the new killer made contact, the
tape cut to black.
During this test, the Slasher seemed more
adept at combat than it had before, as though
it could hear the advice being given to Heather.
With other techniques failing, Field Agent
Tilda-Joan Bennett was brought in for a test,
selected due to her expertise in thaumaturgy.
She instructed Heather on basic offensive
and defensive thaumaturgy, before guiding
her out of the house and into the front yard.
When the Slasher appeared, brandishing their
knife, Heather was able to sign a protective
glyph and defend against the knife’s blow.
She followed this with a wind spell that pushed
the killer further away.
Heather began to run down the driveway, making
a break for survival, when the Slasher suddenly
performed a freeze spell that rendered her
unable to move.
Heather’s wide, panicked eyes stared down
the barrel of the camera in a silent scream
as the killer approached her, recovered knife
in hand, before the tape went black.
Eventually, Dr. Carpenter volunteered to conduct
a test.
He instructed his research team to prepare
a list of options for Heather’s survival,
divided into four categories: What to take
from the basement, where to go once leaving
the basement, how to exit the house, and how
to escape the cul-de-sac.
He was not informed about any of these options,
but rather had them printed out and placed
into plastic bowls on the day of the test.
There were also three cards created and placed
face-down, reading “Face,” “body”,
and “legs.”
When Heather addressed Dr. Carpenter, he informed
her that he would be randomly selecting instructions
for her, and asked that she follow them exactly.
The first slip of paper instructed Heather
to grab a pair of garden shears from the basement,
and climb the stairs back into the main house.
Next, she was told to go upstairs to the bedroom,
then downstairs into the dining room.
She complied, and there was no sign of the
killer so far.
Third, Dr. Carpenter told Heather to run back
upstairs, out the bedroom window, onto the
roof, and then jump down into the garden.
Then, it was time for the next step.
He told Heather to jump over the fence into
the neighbor’s garden, and run down the
street until she could find help.
As Heather made her way down the road, the
Slasher broke through the front door of her
house, but did not chase after her.
Heather continued running down the road for
twenty minutes, as the trees and light began
to dwindle.
The surroundings began to grow darker and
darker, until they resembled a void.
Dr. Carpenter instructed her to keep walking.
She could make out lights and houses in the
distance.
She ran toward the neighborhood, but stopped
suddenly and began to panic.
She was back in her own neighborhood, in front
of her own house, and the killer was waiting
for her.
As Heather demanded to know what to do, Carpenter
flipped over one of the three cards.
It read, “face,” and so he told Heather
to attack the killer’s face with the shears.
Then, the killer’s legs.
Then, his body.
The killer dodged her attack, grabbed the
shears, and pushed her to the ground.
As Heather looked up at the killer, his face
could be seen through the torn sack…it was
Dr. Carpenter.
Heather screamed, and the tape cut to black.
Talk about a third-act twist.
The movie itself did not create the killer,
but somehow the viewer did, and it also made
the killer more creative.
After this incident, all testing on SCP-5733
was suspended, and attempts to help turn Heather
from victim to survivor were halted.
Searching for answers, the Foundation looked
into Crystal Elms Productions, the production
company listed on the video tape’s cover.
No record of the production company, the film,
or any of its cast could be found.
Several months after testing on SCP-5733 was
suspended, another tape was found.
Because let’s face it baby, these days,
you’ve gotta have a sequel.
The new tape was titled “The Suburb Slasher
Strikes Again,” and was purported to be
produced by Crystal Elms Productions in 1985.
It was designated SCP-6733.
Unlike its predecessor, this tape was only
tested once.
A member of D-class personnel was first shown
SCP-5733 up until the point where it became
anomalous, and was then shown SCP-6733.
He was left completely alone in order to watch
the contents of the tape.
The following was what was on it.
Dr. Malcolm Baines entered the testing chamber
to find D-1974, or Jaime, sitting across from
the television set.
He introduced himself, and ran a series of
cognitive tests.
He asked Jaime what he thought of the film,
and he said, “It was pretty much your standard
slasher film.
There's a group of teens who've just graduated
high school and go to a local camping site
by a lake to celebrate.
One of them mentions it's near the site where
the killer, The Slasher, was shot dead by
police a year prior after a rampage-”
Dr. Baines clarified, asking if this was a
reference to the first film.
Jaime continued, “It's not really clear.
They all think it's a joke, apart from the
main girl — she says her dad's a police
officer and she's seen video evidence of the
attack.
No-one references any of the characters from
the first film though, and they don't show
up in this one either.
The Slasher's the only constant.”
According to Jaime, the main events of the
film revolved around a lakeside camping trip
and quickly began to go wrong.
Dr. Baines inquired about the nature of the
Slasher’s kills, and Jaime elaborated, “He's
still got a kitchen knife, same weapon as
the first film, so he stabs a lot of them.
It's pretty gory for the time it was made.
He slashes up someone's face, then the nerdy
guy gets stabbed through the eye — that
one's pretty good, the camera gets sprayed
with blood.
One of the teens gets his head crushed wide
open.”
Dr. Baines asked Jaime how the scenes made
him feel, and he responded, “Like…
there's some good jump scares, and the tension's
fairly high at points, but it's a little dated.
I've seen scarier, but I've also seen worse
horrors.”
Only one part of the film stood out to him:
He described it: “So, the girl and her best
friend, the one that's been looking out for
her this whole time, enter into a cellar.
The Slasher creeps up from behind, and grabs
the friend — tears his head clean off his
neck.
The Slasher then chases the other teen to
the side of the lake.
He's advancing on her.
The camera's set on the water of the lake,
it's a wide shot.
You've got the lake waterline parallel to
the top and bottom of the shot, so it splits
the screen horizontally.
She's fallen over, crawling away from him.
As he advances on her, the camera zooms in
— slowly though.
It takes its time.
He does too.
There's music at the start of the scene: deep,
dark synths.
This stops as the camera moves closer though.
I forgot to say, it's, it's a long scene.
Longer than five minutes, maybe it was ten.
I don't know.
It felt longer than ten.
So the Slasher's approaching her, we're - the
viewers - approaching the shore.
Then the music stops, and it's just his footsteps
and her pleading.
And she's pleading man, she's… there's these
big, inhales of breath stifled by the mucus
running out her nose.
She's babbling, but it gets to a point she's
not even saying words, just making noise.”
As Jaime continued, he began to grow increasingly
distressed.
“The camera's real close to the shore now
— and the Slasher stops.
He turns his head and looks straight at the
camera.
You can't see his eyes, but you know he's
looking straight at you.
And he just stands there, staring.
Eventually the girl crawls out the frame,
or the camera zooms past her.
I can't remember which.
It just keeps zooming in on his face.
Where his face should be under the hood.
The girl keeps screaming off-camera.
Then there's this guttural, ripping noise
and the screaming stops.
It just stops, but the camera keeps moving.
You can see the individual droplets of blood
splashed across him.
You can see the fabrics that make up his hood.
His face soon takes up the entire shot.
And then… black.
No credits or nothing.
The tape just cuts to black, and was pushed
out the player.”
Dr. Baines pushed a bit, asking if there was
anything anomalous he could be forgetting.
then, Jaime thought of something.
“The girl.
Her friends.
All of them.
I don’t think they had names.”
Jaime became increasingly disturbed by the
film over time, calling Dr. Baines into his
dormitory to ask him if they had shown him
a snuff film.
After falling asleep, he had a vivid dream
of the lake, crawling alongside it, recalling
the deaths of his friends at the hand of a
masked killer.
When he woke up, he saw a shadow outside the
window of his room.
It stood there, silent and unmoving, all night.
It only vanished when the sun came up.
The next night, surveillance caught the image
of a humanoid shape running through the forest,
but the guards found no trace of it.
Dr. Baines returned to Jaime’s cell to find
him deeply distressed.
He repeated over and over that the Slasher
was coming for him.
Dr. Baines dismissed this concern.
Once Jaime was alone, he stared into the mirror
as the temperature began to drop.
“You’re here, aren’t you?”
He said.
A gloved hand punched through the mirror,
spraying glass everywhere.
On the other side, there he was: The Suburb
Slasher.
Jaime fled his dormitory and ran for his life,
as the Slasher followed him.
Security Officer Loren confronted the Slasher,
but they lifted him up by the neck and stabbed
the familiar kitchen knife through his head.
Jaime continued to make his way through the
facility, the Slasher following and leaving
a trail of destruction and bodies in his wake.
Then, he reached Dr. Baines, who was confused
by his behavior.
Dr. Baines insisted that the needed to get
to the basement, but, terrified, Jaime resisted
him.
The two men scuffled, and Jaime shoved Dr.
Baines hard, sending him careening into the
wall.
A lighting rig fell from the ceiling, landing
on Dr. Baines.
Several strangers ran into the room, calling
for a medic on-set, and asking for production
and lighting to come back and re-set everything.
Offscreen, a director yelled “Cut!”
The Slasher’s face appeared, taking up the
entirety of the camera, and the tape cut to
black.
This version of the tape’s events was created
after the tape was watched by D-1888 in a
testing session with Dr. Carpenter.
There has never been a Dr. Baines in the SCP
Foundation’s employ.
Somehow, this second tape creates a localized
destabilization of reality.
It is unknown how many times it has actually
been tested.
So be careful what horror rentals you decide
to watch.
You might just find yourself in the middle
of the action, and no matter what you think
you know about surviving a slasher film, there
will be no escape.
You can run, but you can’t hide.
Now go check out “Frightening Lost Ronald
Reagan VHS Tape You Must Watch - SCP-1981
& SCP-095” and “SCP-5094 - Miss J's Whiz
Kidz Schoolhouse” for more mysterious media
SCPs!